the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so we were looking at vector fields
and last time
so last time we saw that if a vector
field happens to be a gradient field
then the line integral can be computed
actually by taking the change in value
of a potential between the end point and
the starting point of the curve ok so if
we have a curve C from a point p0 to a
point p1 then the line integral for work
depends only on the end points and not
on the actual path we choose so we say
that the line integral is path
independent
ok and we also said that the vector
field is conservative because of
conservation of energy which tells you
if you start at a point and you come
back to the same point then you haven't
gotten any work out of that force so if
we have a closed curve then the line
integral for work is just 0
and basically we say that these
properties are equivalent being a
gradient field of being path independent
or being conservative and what I promise
to you is that today we would see a
criterion to decide whether a vector
field is a gradient field or not and how
to find the potential function if it is
a gradient field okay so that's the
topic for today so the question is
testing whether a given vector field
let's say m and n components is a
gradient field so
for that well let's start with an
observation okay so say that it is a
gradient field so that means that the
first component of the field is just the
partial of F with respect to some two
variable X and the second component is a
total of F with respect to Y and now we
have seen an interesting property of the
second partial derivatives of a function
which is if you take the partial
derivative first with respect to X then
with respect to Y or first respect to Y
then with respect to X you get the same
thing so we know F sub XY equals F sub
YX and that means M sub y equals n sub X
okay so if you have a gradient field
then it should have this property
you take the Y component take the
derivative respect to X take the X
component differentiate with respect to
Y you should get the same answer and
that's important to know so I'm going to
put that in the box
it's a walk-in box but okay
and so the claim but I want to make is
that there's a converse of sorts this is
actually basically all we need to check
okay so okay okay so conversely if so
I'm going to put here a condition and my
equals an X then F is a gradient field
so what's the condition that I need to
put here well we'll see a more precise
version of that next week but for now
let's just say if our vector field is
defined and differentiable everywhere in
the plane
okay so we need actually a vector field
that's well defined everywhere you're
not allowed to have somehow places where
it's not well defined otherwise actually
you have a counter example on your
problem set this week if you look at the
last problem and the problem set this
week it gives you a vector field that
satisfies this condition
everywhere where it's defined but
actually there's a point where it's not
defined and that causes it actually to
somehow I mean everything that I'm going
to say today breaks down for that
example because of that so I mean will
shed more light on this a bit later with
the notion of simply connected regions
and so on but for now let's just say if
it's defined everywhere and satisfy this
criterion then it's a gradient field so
if you ignore I mean you know if you
ignore that technical condition being a
gradient field means essentially the
same thing as having this probability so
that's what we need to check
okay so let's look at an example well
one vector field that we've been looking
at a lot was minus y I plus XJ remember
that was the vector field that looked
like rotation at unit speed okay so I
think last time we already decided that
this guy should not be allowed to be a
gradient field and should not be
conservative because if we integrate on
the unit circle then we'll get a
positive answer but let's check that
indeed it fails our test so well let's
call this guy M let's let's call this
guy n then if you look at partial M
partial Y well that's going to be
negative one if you take partial n
partial X that's going to be one and
these are not the same so indeed this is
not a variant field
okay any questions about that yes
okay so your question is if I have that
property M sub y equals n sub X only in
a certain domain in certain part of the
plane for some values of x and y can i
conclude these things and you know that
it's a gradient field in that part of
the plane and conservative and so on so
the answer for now is in general no and
when we spend more time on it actually
maybe I should move that that maybe
we'll talk about it then you know later
this week instead of when I planned but
so there's a notion of what it means for
a region to be without holes and
basically if you have that kind of
property in a region that doesn't have
any holes inside it then things will
work the problem comes from your vector
field satisfying this criterion in a
region that has a hole in it because
then what you don't know is whether your
potential is actually well-defined and
takes the same value when you move all
around the hole it might come back to
take a different value if you look
carefully and think hard about the
example on the problem set that's
exactly what happens there anyway I mean
again I will say more about that later
but so for now we basically need our
function to be I mean so I should still
say you know if you have this property
for a vector field that's not quite
defined everywhere you're more than
welcome you know you should probably
still try to look for a potential using
the methods that we'll see but something
might go wrong later
you know you might end up with a
potential that's not well defined
okay let's do another example so let's
say that I give you this vector field
and the question is you know so this a
here is a number question is for which
value of a is this going to be possibly
a gradient so if you have you know your
flashcards then that's a good time to
use them to vote assuming that when
number is small enough to be made with
okay so let's try to think about it so
we want to call this guy M we want to
call that guy N and we want to test ms
of y versus n sub X okay I don't see
anyone oh yeah okay I see people doing
it with their hands and that works very
well well okay so question is sorry for
which value of a is this a gradient
yeah okay so I see various people with
regard to answer and yes okay that's a
strange answer on the but yeah I see
okay that's a good answer
okay so if a vote seems to be four
equals eight and let's see well if I
take M sub y that is going to be just a
X and n sub X that is 8 X so I would
like equals 8 by the way so when you set
these two equal to each other they
really have to be equal everywhere right
so you don't want to somehow solve for X
or anything like that you just want
these expressions in terms of x and y to
be the same quantities you know I mean
you can't say well if x equals 0 they're
always equal yeah that's true but that's
not what we're asking ok so now we come
to the next stage of you know the next
logical question let's say that we've
passed the test so we've put equals 8 in
here so now it should be a potential so
it should be a gradient field the
question is how do we find the potential
so that becomes 8 from now on the
question is how do we find the function
which has verses gradient so one option
is to try to guess and actually quite
often you will succeed that way but
that's not a valid method on next week's
test so we're going to see two different
systematic methods and you should be
using one of these because well guessing
doesn't always work and actually you
know I can come up with I mean I can
come up with examples where if you try
to guess you will surely fail I can come
up with trick ones but I don't want to
put back on the test but still
so okay so the next stage is finding the
potential and let me just emphasize we
can only do that if you know step one
was successful if we don't have you know
if we have a vector field that cannot
possibly be a gradient then we shouldn't
try to look for potential it's kind of
obvious but it's probably worth pointing
out so that's two methods and the first
method that we'll see is by computing
line integrals so let's see how that
works
so let's say that you know I start I
take some path that starts at the origin
or actually anywhere you want but let's
take the origin that's my favorite point
and let's go to a point with coordinates
say X minus y one okay and let's take my
favorite curve and let's compute the
line integral of that field along you
know the work done along the curve well
by the fundamental theorem that should
be equal to the value of the potential
at the endpoint minus the value at the
origin well so that means I can actually
write f of x1 y1 equals bless you
equals that line integral plus the value
at the origin and that's just you know a
constant we don't know what it is and
actually we can choose what it is
because if you have a potential you know
save as you have some potential function
and let's say that you add one to it
it's still a potential function I think
one doesn't change the gradient you can
even add 18 or any number that you want
so this is just going to be an
integration constant you know it's the
same thing as in one variable calculus
when you take the antiderivative of a
function it's only defined up to adding
a constant so we have this integration
constant but apart from that we know
that we should be able to get our
potential from this and this we can
compute using the definition of the line
integral because we know well we don't
know what little F is but we know what
the vector field is so we can compute
that
well of course to do the calculation we
probably don't want to use this kind of
path I mean you know if that's your
favorite path then that's fine but it's
not very easy to compute the line
integral along this especially since I
didn't tell you what the definition is
so you know there's easier favorite
paths to have for example you can go on
a straight line from the origin to that
point that would be slightly easier but
in fact that's even easier the easiest
of all probably is to just go first
along the x-axis to x1 0 and then go up
parallel to the y-axis why is that easy
well that's because when we do the line
integral becomes M DX plus n dy and then
on each of these pieces 1/2 just goes
away because X or Y is constant so
let's do let's try to use that method on
our example
okay so
okay so let's say that I'm going to
integrate sorry how do I end up with two
okay so let's say that I want to go
along this path from the origin first
along the x axis to x10 then vertically
to x1 y1 and so I want to compute the
line integral along that curve so let's
say I want to do it for this vector
field okay I want to find the potential
for this vector field so here okay let
me copy it because I'll have to erase at
some point so it's 4x squared plus 8xy
and 3y squared plus 4x squared so that
will become the integral of 4x squared +
8 X Y DX plus 3y squared plus 4x squared
dy now to evaluate on this broken line I
will of course evaluate separately on
each of the two segments so I'll start
with the segment that I will call c1 and
when I will do this one that I call c2
so on Siwon how do I evaluate my
integral well if I Munsey 1 then X
varies from 0 to X 1 well actually I
don't know if X 1 is positive or not so
if you don't write this and we should
say just X goes from 0 to X 1
and what about y y is just 0 so I will
set y equal 0 and also dy equal to 0 so
I get that the line integral don't see
one well a lot of stuff goes away right
so the entire second term with dy goes
away because dy is 0 and in the first
term 8xy goes away because Y is 0 as
well so I just have integral of 4x
squared DX from 0 to X 1 so by the way
now you see why I've been using x1 and
y1 for my point and not just x and y
it's to avoid confusion you know I'm
using x and y as my integration
variables and x1 y1 as constants that
are representing the endpoint of my path
okay and so if I integrate this I should
get 4/3 X 1 cubed okay so that's the
first part and next I need to do the
second segment
so if I'm on c2 so Y goes from zero to
y1 and what about X yeah X is constant
equal to x1 so DX becomes just zero it's
a constant so if I take the line
integral and see - oops - here I have
the V R then I will get the integral
from zero to y1 of so the entire first
term with DX goes away and then I have
3y squared plus 4 well X is X 1 X 1
squared dy
ok so that integrates to Y cubed plus
4x1 squared Y from 0 to y 1 if you
prefer that's y 1 cubed plus 4x1 squared
Y 1 ok so now that we have done both of
them we can just add them together and
that will give us the formula for the
potential
[Applause]
okay so f of x1 and y1 is 4/3 X 1 cubed
plus y 1 cubed plus 4 X 1 squared Y 1
plus a constant okay that constant is
just the integration constant that we
had from the beginning
so you know now you can drop the
subscripts if you prefer you can just
say F is 4/3 X cubed plus y cubed plus 4
x squared y plus constant okay and you
can check if you take the gradient of
this then you should get again this
vector field over there
okay any questions about this method yes
no well it depends whether you are just
trying to find one potential oh if
you're trying to find all the possible
potentials if a problem just says find a
potential then you don't have to include
the constant you know this guy we
thought the constant is a valid
potential just you have others you know
so if your neighbor comes to you and
says oh you're handsome has before me I
got this plus 18 well you know both
answers are correct okay
by the way so instead of going first
along the x axis then vertically you
could do it the other way around of
course start along the y axis then
always on turi and you know that's the
same level of difficulty
it just exchange the roles of x and y in
some cases it's actually even making
more sense maybe to go radially straight
out from the origin to your end point
but usually this setting is easier just
because see each of these two guys was
actually very easy to compute
but somehow maybe if you suspect that
polar coordinates will be involved
somehow in the answer then maybe it
makes sense to choose different paths
maybe a straight line is better okay
so now we have another method to look at
which is using anti-derivatives okay so
I mean the goal is the same still to
find the potential function and you see
that finding the potential is really the
you know multivariable analogue of
finding the antiderivative in one
variable so you know here we did it
basically by hand by computing the
integral the other thing you could try
to say is wait I already know how to
take anti derivatives let's use that
instead of computing integrals and it
works but you have to be careful about
how you do it so let's see how that
works
okay so let's still do it with the same
example so we want to solve the
equations we want a function such that f
sub X is 4x squared + 8 X Y and F sub y
is 3y squared + 4 x squared so let's
just look at one of these at the time if
we look at this one well we know how to
solve this because it's just telling us
we have to integrate this with respect
to X ok well let's call them 1 & 2
because I will have to refer to them
again
so let's start with equation 1 and let's
integrate with respect to X while it
tells us that F should be okay so what
do I get when I integrate this with
respect to X I get 4/3 X cubed plus when
I integrate 8 XY Y is just a constant so
I will get 4 x squared Y and that's not
quite the end to it ok because there's
an integration constant and here when I
save as an integration constant it just
means the extra term does not depend on
X that's what it means to be a constant
in this setting but maybe my constant
still depends on Y so it's not actually
a true constant a constant that depends
on Y is not really a constant it's
actually a function of Y okay so the
good news that we have is that this
function no longer depends on X so it
should be you know we've made some
progress we've got part of the answer
and you know we've simplified the
problem so if we have anything that
looks like this it will satisfy the
first condition so now we need to look
at the second condition okay so we want
F sub y to be that and well so but we
know what F is so let's compute F sub y
from this ok so from this I get that F
sub y so what do I get if I
differentiate this with respect to Y
when I get 0 plus 4 x squared plus the
derivative of G so
I would like to match this with what I
had so if I match this with equation two
then that will tell me what the
derivative of G should be
okay so if we compare the two things
there we get 4x squared plus G prime of
Y should be equal to say Y squared plus
4x ad and of course the 4x squares go
away that tells you G prime is flay y
squared and that integrates 2y cubed
plus constant now this time the constant
is at all constant okay because G did
not depend on anything other than Y and
the constant does not depend on Y so
it's really it's a real constant now so
now we just plug this back into this guy
let's call him star if we plug this into
star we get F equals 4/3 X cubed plus 4
x squared y plus y cubed plus constant
and I mean of course again now this
constant is optional so see the
advantage of this method is you don't
have to write any integrals the small
drawback is you have to follow this
procedure carefully so by the way one
common pitfall you know it's tempting so
after you've done this what's very
tempting is to just say oh well let's do
the same with this guy let's integrate
this with respect to Y you'll get
another expression for F up to a
constant that depends on X and then
let's match them well the difficulty is
matching is actually quite tricky
because you don't know in advance
whether they're really the same
expression you know it could be that I
got you know you could say oh let's just
take the terms that are here I'm missing
there and combine you know the terms
that are you know take all the terms
that appear in either one
that's actually not a good way to do it
because if I put sufficiently
complicated trig functions in there then
you might not be able to see that two
terms are the same you know take an easy
one let's say that here I have one plus
tangent square and here I have a
cotangent square so I have a I mean
secant square then you know you might
not actually notice that there's a
difference but there's no difference oh
well whatever
okay so anyway so I'm saying you know do
it this way don't do it any other way
because there's a risk of making a
mistake otherwise I mean on the other
hand of course you could start with
integrating with respect to Y and then
differentiate and match with relative
respect to X but so what I'm saying is
just you know take one of them integrate
get an answer that involves a function
of the other variable then differentiate
that answer and compare and see what you
get by the way yeah so here of course
you know after we simplified there were
only wise here there were no X's and
that's kind of good news I mean if you
hide higher than X and X here in this
expression that would have told you that
something is going wrong right G is a
function of Y only so if you get an X
here maybe you want to go back and check
whether it is really a gradient field
yes yes this will work with functions of
more than two variables both methods
will work with more than two variables
so we're going to see it in the case
where more than two means free we're
going to see that in a two or three
weeks from now
I mean basically starting at the end of
next week we're going to do triple
integrals line integrals in space and so
on
so the format is first we do everything
in two variables then we'll do it in
three variables and what happens with
more than three will be left to your
imagination
okay any other questions about either of
these methods okay a quick poll would
prefer the first method who prefers the
second method well okay
so well anyway I mean you get to use
whichever one you want and I would agree
with you but the second method is
slightly more effective in that you're
writing less stuff you don't have to you
know setup or design integrals for
nothing on the other hand it does
require a little bit more of attention
okay
so well let's move on a bit
well let me start by actually doing a
small recap so we said we have various
notions one is to say that the vector
field is a gradient in a certain region
of a plane and we have another notion
which is being conservative which says
that the integral the line integral is
zero along any closed curve so actually
let me introduce a new piece of notation
so to just to remind ourselves that we
are doing it along a closed curve very
often we put just a circle for the
integral to tell us well this is a curve
that you know closes on itself it ends
where it started I mean it doesn't
change anything
concerning the definition or how you
compute it or anything it just reminds
you that you're doing it on a closed
curve it's actually useful for various
physical applications and also you know
when you state theorems in that way it
reminds it reminds you oh I need to be
on a closed curve to do it and so we've
said these two things are equivalent and
now we have a third thing which is n sub
x equals M sub y at every point
so just to summarize the discussion
we've said if we have a gradient field
then we have this and the converse is
true in suitable regions so we have a
converse if F is defined in the entire
plane or as we'll see soon in a simply
connected region okay I guess some of
you can see what I'm writing here but it
doesn't matter because you're not
officially supposed to know it yet that
will be next week okay anyway so I said
the fact that NX equals my implies we
have a gradient field is only if a
vector field is defined in the entire
plane or in a region that's called
simply connected and more about that
later so now let me just introduce a
quantity that probably a lot of you have
heard about in physics that measures
precisely failure to be conservative
let's call the curl of a vector field
okay so Oh
so definition we say that the curl of F
is the quantity n sub X minus M sub y
okay so it's just you know vapor caging
information we had but in a way that's a
single quantity okay so in this new
language the conditions that we have the
condition that we had over there this
condition says curl F equals zero that's
the new version of an x equals n way
okay so it measures failure of the
vector field to be conservative so I
should probably test for
conservativeness is that the curl of F
should be zero so I should probably tell
you a little bit about what the curl is
what it measures what it does because
that's something that's wholly useful
it's a very strange quantity right if
you put it in that form I mean yes
I think it's the same as the physics one
but I haven't checked the physics
textbook recently but I believe it's the
same yes I think it's the same as with
physics one it's not the opposite this
time of course in physics maybe you've
seen actually curl in space and we are
going to see curl in space in two or
three weeks but yes yes well you can
also use it so if you fail this test
then you know for sure that you're not a
gradient field so you might as well do
that if you satisfy the test but you're
not defined everywhere when there's
still a bit of a minuite and you don't
know for sure okay okay so let's try to
see a little bit what the curl measures
so I want to claim that you know just to
give you some intuition let's first
think about a velocity field the curl
again curl measures the rotation
component of a motion if you want a
fancy word that measures the vorticity
of a motion it tells you how much
twisting is taking place at a given
point okay so for example you know if I
take well if I take a constant vector
field you know where my fluid is just
all moving in the same place in the same
so in the same direction you know where
this is just constants then of course
the curl is zero because if you take the
partials you get zero and indeed that's
not what you would call you know
swelling I mean there's no there's no
vortex in here
on the other hand well okay now let's do
another one where there's still nothing
going on let's say that I take you know
the radial vector field where everything
just flows away from the origin so
that's F equals X comma Y well if I take
the curl so I have to take partial
partial x of the second component which
is y minus partial partial Y of the
first component which is X I will get
zero and indeed you know if you put you
know if you think about what's going on
here there's no rotation involved on the
other hand if you consider our favorite
rotation vector field negative Y and X
then its curl is going to be well n sub
X minus M sub y will be 1 plus 1 equals
2 and that corresponds to the fact that
we are rotating actually we are rotating
at unit angular speed so the curl
actually measures twice the angular
speed of the rotation part of a motion
at any given point so now if you have an
actual motion you know a more
complicated field than these then no
matter where you are you can think of
the motion as a combination of
translation effects maybe dilation
effects may be a rotation effects
possibly other things like that and what
the curl will come will measure is how
intense the rotation effect is at that
particular point okay so I'm not going
to try to make a much more precise
statement when I'm in the quiz I
statement is you know what curl measures
is really this quantity up there but the
intuition you should have is it measures
how much rotation is taking place at any
given point and of course in a
complicated motion you
have more rotation at some point at some
others which is why the curve will
depend on x and y it's not just a
constant because you know how much short
it depends on where you are
so you know if you're looking at actual
wind velocities in weather protection
then the regions with high curl tend to
be hurricanes or tornadoes or things
like that they're not very pleasant
things and the sign of the curl tells
you whether you're going clockwise or
counterclockwise
okay so care measures well twice the
angular velocity of the rotation
component of a velocity field now what
about the force field because after all
you know where we got to this was coming
from and trying to understand forces and
the work we do so if you tell you what
it means for force
well the curl of a force field
measures the torque exerted on you know
a test object that you put at any point
so remember torque is the rotational
analog of the force you know we had this
analogy about velocity versus angular
velocity and mass versus moment of
inertia and when in that analogy you
know a force divided by the mass is what
will cause acceleration which is the
derivative of velocity torque divided by
moment of inertia is what will cause the
angular acceleration namely the
derivative of angular velocity maybe
actually I should write that down
oops
okay so talk / moment of inertia is
going to be DDT of angular velocity I
leave it up to your physics teachers to
decide what let us to use for all these
things but the analog of force divided
by mass equals acceleration which is DDT
of velocity and so now you see if the
curl of a velocity field measures the
angular velocity of its rotation then
you know by this analogy the curl of a
force field should measure the torque it
exhausts it exerts on a mass per unit
moment of inertia
so concretely if you imagine that you're
putting something in there you know if
you're in a velocity field the curl will
tell you how fast your guy is spinning
at a given time you know if you put
something that floats for example your
fluid you know something that I lied
then it's going to start spinning and
the curl of a velocity field tells you
how fast it is spinning at any given
time
up to a factor of two and the curl of a
force field tells you how quickly the
angular velocity is going to increase or
decrease okay so on well next time we
are going to see greens theorem which is
actually going to tell us a lot more
about curl and failure of
conservativeness